and some money here's how
[Applause]
here in nevada in las vegas why
shouldn't you have solar it's it's it
makes all the sense in the world it
makes sense financially because we have
so much sunshine we have 360 days of
sunshine every year
so solar pays for itself you don't even
need to
call it an investment because what you
pay for solar you get paid back by
having lower
or no power builds regularly every month
so we were doing mostly residential
solar projects a few commercial
uh projects so meaning we put solar on
residential homes
we sell the systems we engineered the
system so we have an in-house
engineering team
which pretty much no one else does so
we have our own installation crew which
is
a crucial element of a solar company
today if you look around with all these
companies you have in town right now i
believe it's
up to i don't know even 90 companies
right now
almost none of them have their
installation team so they're basically
nothing else than
a sales office selling a solar system
and then
bring it to some contractor to install
the system
so we do everything in-house everything
connected and obviously this is really
the way to do it
to get the best quality in all stages of
the project
well let's face it uh solar is a
significant amount of money you have to
spend so it's all about trust
and so the solar industry is fairly
unique in the world
where else do you have warranties that
cover like 25 years
just imagine you would have a car with a
25-year warranty
so this makes it really really unique
but the warranties are not worth the
paper if you cannot trust
the company the suppliers that are
behind these warranties
and that's why it's important that we've
been here on the market for more than 10
years
and probably stay here for more than 10
years compared to a lot of other
companies that
just went out of business after just a
few months of business on operations
the night outside is our newest employee
so
he is there to demonstrate what seoul is
all about
it's about protection protecting
the safety of our customers having power
even in the worst periods
but it's also about protecting
investment so we don't know what energy
prices are going to do
in the future and with the solar system
you're protected it's like a home
insurance on energy rates
people see us from the streets and we
want to give clients the feeling
that they can trust that if there is any
issue
they're not talking to a person maybe
sitting in india
or the philippines so if you have an
issue
with us just come on in the doors are
open you can even talk to me
call soul up at 702-586-9800 or just
head to seoulup.com and fyi
they guarantee installation or soul-up
will pay the difference
in tax credit they're taking care of you
las vegas now we'll be right back